it's a it's a beautiful thing to be able
to because in my eyes music comes from
God like it's uh something that he has
created like that we can use to our
advantage to make us closer no but
historically speaking I have respected
historically speaking music does not
bring you to closer to God and uh let me
let us lay down foundation for you to
understand the point and inshaallah will
be clear to you yes
in order now to work for example if you
want to buy a gift for your mother would
you buy a gift that your love or your
mother love
it's one about your love because you
wanna buy something that she's happy
with yes now if you're going to work
another example energy if you're going
to work
and the boss he wants you to do
something that you make him happy or to
make his business successful are you
good according to you are you going to
do according to your desires and
according to the way you're gonna feel
according to the structure and the the
the guideline that the manager has given
you
wisdom and Allah Justice when Allah
create us he never left it up to our
feelings and our intellects to come to
conclusion how to worship Him
because we have different ways we have
different feelings yes generally
speaking we know there's a Creator
actually worshiped no doubt about that
however how to worship Him in details
you need a guideline from who from your
creator you understand like this is a
secret
this is the music
the frontier is that with Allah he is
the creator of everything when he
legislate something we know sometimes we
can know the wisdom behind it sometimes
we don't know however we know that we
have a little wisdom and a little
knowledge and we know the creator has a
perfect wisdom a perfect knowledge do
you agree so it's a logical if you don't
mind can we move back sorry sister you
know just said because there are people
shouting so what are we saying that it's
illogical
irrational that us we should utilize our
small knowledge our small our feelings
to
dictate to the all-knowing to the most
wise how should we get closer to him so
Allah mentioned music is Haram no doubt
about that you know because why one of
the things that people used to do to
turn people away from God Is by
listening to music
and and even scores mentioned in music
is like Satan way to turn people away
from God because many people sometimes
they feel they're doing something good
but in a reality is something bad that's
why in order for us to get closer to God
first let's be based upon knowledge
which knowledge not our feelings the
knowledge that come from the Creator
is
that science so the meaning of the verse
was revealed because there was a man he
used to bring singers from Persia and
when he used to see people going to
listen to the Quran he used to tell them
why are you going to listen to Muhammad
come listen to the singer okay so Allah
I mentioned that these 10 people away
from God Allah
so but that should not stop you because
me even myself I was born as a Muslim
okay of course there was a time when I
once misguided you know turned away from
God you know
and when I start practicing I used to
listen to music
but the reason I mentioned that to show
you sister even if you listen to music
should not stop you from accepting and
worshiping your creator
that everything's around us and even
Islamic teaching go in line and show us
clear proofs that Islam is a truth that
should not prevent you because
if you imagine deaf judgments or imagine
you die today Mala forbid and you stand
before your Creator and he said the
reason I never accept you because of
music
do you think that would be a valid
reason when you know that you should
worship your creator according to his
teaching not according to the way you're
feeling
that will not be vital reason so do you
think it's like
an earth there's a test was like alcohol
clubbing music do you think the music's
been created as a test book yeah it's a
test no doubt yeah as I told you and how
music started the scores mentioned Adam
had two sons
okay Adam
so the decision of Adam
some of them they were righteous and
some of them they were evil
Satan came as a young person too
those who are as evil people or they'll
do evil
and he started teaching them how to sing
that's how the music came about you know
so it goes back to you to shaytan you
know so of course music is a test it's a
test for me Allah even me there's some
music I should listen to
yeah
there's some music I listened to as when
I'm walking past and I see people
listening to it I just put my like you
know I'm scared because it's a fitness
is a tribe for me instead it's a test
but however if you leave something for
the sake of Allah Allah will replace you
something better than it and what is
that which is something that best listen
to the Quran that's how I stop listening
to music because it is impossible that
you listen to the Quran the speech of
Allah and you know the Quran you know
about the music here regardless if it's
a classic music or not it gives you like
a fake
you know what is the music
you you it's like you start and where's
the word
um
you feel like connected yeah but when
you turn it off even it goes off
the Quran
because even me before when I start
thinking about what is the music Quran
Quran when you when you listen to Quran
Quran will it affect your heart will it
affect your heart affect your limbs when
you affect your limbs you start acting
into the society so you are living the
Quran you are implementing the Quran you
know that's why the beauty of the Quran
the music like some people listen to
hip-hop music yeah I am Gangnam Style
I'm gonna kill everyone he turns off the
the music then you remember he lives in
a council house he has to pay the bills
he'll remember tomorrow has to go to
school so all that fake imagination
likewise
yeah
when you listen to it when you send it
off you still feeling it and it push you
to implement it about if it's like music
about Islam
you know you remind me of
you remind me of someone even that but
you know there's something called
crochet in Arabic
poor a poem who should do with
Melody but without instrumental music
because
you can listen to this you know some
people doing English you know there's
like a poem they do with a nice voice
is allowed we'll go back to the poem and
everything but the harab is instrumental
music
it will come a time
you know so even this so-called Islamic
music is how long does it make any sense
it's like you're going to what they call
it uh or someone should do fornication
is that Islamic communication doesn't
make any sense you know so what we say
to your sister don't let this thing to
stop you because look when I start
practicing like I said there was many
things it was very hard for me to live
but I acknowledged I said my own
existence everything me personally and
whatever is surrounding me
and nothing should stop me because look
look at Allah's Mercy Allah knows that
we are weak so even if you're doing if
you become Muslim and you listen to
music you know increase Good Deeds you
know you know
listen to the Quran you know
alhamdulillah don't let these things
stop you to become a Muslim you come
from a Muslim family that is your
parents Muslim yeah I was around 16 by
myself so I lived here by myself a long
time okay you know so like you're always
going to say anyway
I think that it's kind of hard to blame
somebody for who they've what religion
they perform if they're atheist or not
because like even my parents they do I
don't think they've even met someone
who's Muslim because they're living in a
place where there's no Muslims like and
they are never really exposed to it at
all and then that's for the majority of
people in my town like nobody where you
from you don't mind if you don't huh
Glasgow yeah
a lot of them as well are atheists like
how are they ever going to be exposed
there's answer for it Allah said
Allah will never punish anyone until the
proof becomes clear to them so if
someone lives like in your town and she
dies or he dies as a Christian then
expose Islam on a day of Resurrection
Allah will never punish them straight
away Allah will test them because Allah
is just because like my wife is a river
my wife she came from a Christian
background likewise many times 14 okay
and uh same thing
not much to have life but she came to
Country when she was 12 or something you
know she was in solution and she didn't
know about Islam and she for Islam is
like you know the question since that
time she was not exposed to Islam
Islam was exposed to Islam she said made
sense to me and she said Islam when she
was 14. so alhamdulillah Islam teach us
Islam is just sister even if someone
heard about Islam but it's insane
Allah because one of the conditions for
Allah to judge people and Allah for
himself
Allah put it for himself sanity
Christianity gives you the ability to
differentiate between right and wrong if
you don't understand it if you are
insane you cannot do that so that's why
Prophet Muhammad mentioned there's three
types of people the pen is being lifted
from the middle not behold accountable
one of them is an insane person one of
them is a young boy who has not reached
the age of puberty the other person who
is sleeping imagine I'm sleeping and I
insult Islam Allah because I was not in
my consciousness
her father
her father died when we explained Islam
to him I mean before he died I speak to
him but he went to Mission he went crazy
you know I preach Allah to he passed the
test on the day of resurrection and you
go to Jannah Allah is the most Justice
for like say example you want to make a
prayer for your wife father your prayers
now in in like in this day and age will
affect his his like judgment on Judgment
Day like your opinion of him like your
pastor Allah it depends if you sincere
you know Allah
is there also Allah knows about the
person who should not know you
understand
like for example I mentioned this thing
here I always pray to Allah he gives me
but there's one thing I've been asking
for the last maybe 15 years I don't have
it
this thing is really affecting my life
you have no problem in your life but I
know I'm looking at Allah gave me many
things if Allah has not giving me that
thing therefore it's not good for me
even I think it's affecting my life but
Allah is the old wise so Allah because
you know as a human being we judge
actions or things based upon the
apparents you're with me you know that's
what in the Quran there's a story of the
young boy of the Heather and Musa when
Heather he was a prophet of Allah who
Allah gave him the knowledge of the
inward things and when you do an action
what he leads to so he killed a young
boy Moses said to him why are you
killing a young boy who was an innocent
person I mean all of us if we see this
man killing a young boy what is he doing
but he said to him the reason I killed
him he was going to grow up as an evil
person and make his family suffer and
make them disbelievers to go to Hell
Fire so I saved him from his own evil
and I saved his family too you see so
look subhanallah as judge actions that
could happen earthquake and everything
there's no doubt there's wisdom behind
it sometimes we know sometimes we don't
know an example I give always imagine
all of us here
we are standing and we see someone
holding soul and cutting someone's
forearm yeah you're with me cutting
someone's forearm all of us we're going
to think what he's a crazy man he's
mentally Disturbed then you go to him
say oh crazy person stop what you're
doing say no I'm not crazy this person
has a deadly disease in his forearm and
if I let it grow spread it will kill him
so I'm cutting off save his life what is
it now evil or good he's a good person
so one example sometimes maybe you pray
to Allah
knows he will not give it to you because
Allah knows what is good for you is bad
or he knows about the person you
understand do you think that Allah can
enter your thoughts at any point no no
Allah we don't say Allah answered our
thoughts
that's right Allah inspire you sometimes
inspire you meaning that I will guide
you to do something which is uh we don't
say a revelation because the revelation
we say inspire you to do something which
is yeah
how do you know if that thought is
coming from aloe if it's coming from
that's a good point
orange is good at this point I said then
because we have a criteria what is the
criteria is the revelation of Allah
which we can establish with certainty
and knowledge and clear proofs is from
Allah and our thoughts that's what the
school has mentioned our thoughts and
our dreams cannot change our legislation
because our legislation is the criteria
that's why side points that's why when
we speak to Christians they say about
the Holy Spirit but we're going to tell
them listen we cannot even verify the
Holy Spirit you claim to have a holy
spirit he claims to have Holy Spirit and
you are saying the completely different
thing so how can we judge but we as
Muslims we have the Quran and the Sunnah
and tell you here sister here brother
read and you can see it's a rectangible
so if your thoughts tell you to do
something even okay then you go back to
Father for example imagine Satan say I'm
a prophet it tells me I'm a prophet of
God say no no no wait online clearly
said Muhammad is the last prophet so I
know this from Satan if someone if Satan
tell me come listen to music it by by
whoever listened to music you get across
Allah said no no the qurani verses that
had it clearly say music is Haram
someone tells me about smoking drugs you
know I met a guy literally that's why he
said to me he said you know how a
mediate you know how I worship God this
is how he said by smoking spliff
said look doesn't mean because you feel
good at that time he makes it right you
understand that's why you know us
feeling good about something doesn't
make it right because we don't want to
take ecstasy or cocaine or start feeling
good at that moment but doesn't make it
right you understand my sister so yeah
so the Quran Sunnah is the criteria to
determine if our thought is our right
foot or wrongful or are the dreams that
we have Prophet Muhammad told us there
is type of dreams that we have it's
Allah but how do you know go back to
Spanish if I see a dream
again or uh
my father told if I see a dream that
Allah told me uh quote unquote Allah
told me do not pray anymore I said no
there's a lie that's not my Allah
because Allah said to his Prophet who
Allah has forgiven all his shortcomings
he said
worship your lord until you die
there's no taking break you understand
is that clear
[Music]
ly
of course Allah you know shaytan on the
day of judgment he will give a ceremony
he will give a talk to mankind
and he would say to mankind Ibrahim he
will say to them I just called you and
you answered my call
I never forced you you just and I I told
you it was a pure lie and Allah told you
it was the truth I'm not going to save
you and you're not going to save me and
Allah even mentioned in another verse
Satan he will betray the son of Adam
or the daughter of Adam so the Satan
will be punched with the fire no doubt
he will receive because remember why
shaytan hates us because Satan was an
arrogant person but the Angels before
that he was a righteous person from the
appearance
he was a gym that's right we don't
believe he was Angel that's a Christian
Christian teaching but Islamic you
believe he was a Jin as Allah clearly
it's a state in the Quran so that's why
you know test what Allah tests us and in
Arabic we call tests
Into the Fire to see if there's a real
God or fake so Allah puts people into
the test and all that see if they are
True Believers or not because I can
claim to be a believer of God I love God
but since Allah put me in the trust I'll
turn away from it as Allah said in the
Quran
some people wish Allah on the edge
literally on the edge is something good
happened to him you say Islam is good I
love Muslims there's something bad
happened to him it says with Allah Allah
this person will lose this life and day
after so shaytan will be
that that's why sister it's not for you
to take that decision say you know what
I don't want to flush Satan I want to
follow Allah you know I mean
like I said no one knows we're only
going to die
there's nothing guaranteeing this stuff
except death how many people left the
houses and never come back how many
people won't sleep they never wake up
that's what Allah all mankind everyone
prepare yourself for the day of
Resurrection
on the day of Resurrection when the man
will run away from his son the mother
would run away with my daughter on that
day ever say myself myself
the intoxication of death come with the
truth when you're about to die I'm not
sure if you had a panic attack before
when you got confused you don't know
what's happening to you when the death
comes to one of us the veil will be
removed you see the ends in front of you
who is going to benefit you enough
except your law believe in your Creator
and believe in Allah this life all these
amusements all of these Temptations in
this life is nothing in comparison to
the Hereafter I was watching Dubai you
know Dubai Masha Allah is so beautiful
Dubai it's like different world man
Dubai so beautiful masha'allah I said to
my wife watching together I said you
know this is why we see
in comparison to Paradise it's like a
bin
would you be in Jannah do when you
compare Paradise to Dubai now you look
as it's a rubbish place what we're doing
here Jannah Paradise that's why you know
even our time the 8th is scientists they
want to look for eternity
is the most wise
eternity in this life is not be fitting
it's a punishment why or you get sick
earthquake you don't want to live for
long like this you have children
children have children you start feeling
stressed you have to do many things so
look Allah is wise
eternity is good for Paradise as for the
evil ones eternity in jahannam
because the greatest sin against Allah
will turn away from him you understand
that's why you have the choice now to
accept Islam to reject it to worship
your God and I always mention this
example sister
imagine you are in the house may Allah
forbid you wake up and there's a fire
everywhere all right you try your best
to Serve Yourself
you try and you couldn't you gave up if
whenever it's over I'm dying I came and
I saved your life what would you say to
me
if I saved your life what would you say
to me would you remember me all the time
I saved your life no doubt you're gonna
remember that brother Hashem still saved
my life so why would why we don't
remember and be grateful to the one who
gave us a life for free
you know that's why you know the number
earlier mentioned about the gifts
likewise if you want to worship your
creator be grateful to Him worship Him
the way he wants that's what Allah means
in the Quran
um
they have not commanded except to
worship Allah sincerely why sincerely
for his sake likewise Allah
be upon righteousness the way you have
been commanded not the way we feel you
understand and you know sorry you want
to ask questions
no Islam is based upon love and Faith
and Hope
Justice I love Allah
and I fear his punishments and our hope
that he will forgive me and answer me to
paradise
the intention is
this way because I want to make sure
that I'm protected but like it worries
me that I will go because you know if uh
if a Muslim leaves Islam it's worse than
somebody who is atheist is that right
yes because he knew the truth yeah and
he turned away from it that's right yeah
so it's only that kind of
[Music]
thing
yeah but you know sister look we have to
understand
I was speaking to many people come to me
said not many people some people say why
Allah is going to punish people when
they have fire I said no the question
should not be this why Allah is going to
punish people you should ask the people
all people why you want to go to Hell
Fire
that's the question should be because if
you like for example one person came to
me he said to me
um
it was a it was a a guy in service Bush
what Allah is going to punish us forever
I said you believe that he said yes I
said so save yourself
if you don't believe that's what the
problem is not going to punch us or not
the people don't even believe in God so
it will be different topic in the stand
that's what Allah taught us you know
even how Allah mentioned how he's going
to punish us in details in the Quran the
score is mentioned that is immersive
from Allah to show us that his anger is
severe and Punishment so if you know
that 10 away from it but Allah knows
you're weak
so if you're a Muslim and you do even
act better than a non-muslim why first
how because the biggest and the worst
evil act of worship when you turn away
completely from your God
you know because like I said your own
existence by its own virtue while we're
speaking we are benefiting from
everything our eyes from our from the
earth imagine from the oxygen if you go
to hospital you'll be charged for the
oxygen you know then they charge you
Allah has given it to you for free
everything's for free you know Allah's
blessings you know but you choose turn
away from it except it goes back to
arrogance you understand so don't let
the because remember Sister we have
to understand it's good to feel for
yourself and to check your intention
even me teaching in front of the people
I fear for my intention that's how the
Muslim should be you have some a Muslim
characteristic no doubt but also Satan
can use that think and guess too for
example in Islam will not allow you to
show off
so sometimes maybe you're praying in the
most and someone's sitting down and you
are praying Satan will come he will come
to you so I pray quick pray quick
because you're showing off the score is
mentioned no prolong it more longer
that's how you're that's how you defeat
Satan because Satan remember Satan has
been around I don't know how many years
but it's very experienced
it's very experienced he knows how to
get into every individual
what was it made first the I don't know
if it's a stupid question but no no no
ask you know but no I know if I don't
know I don't know it was hell created
first or well it was how great for
shaytan it was having just a place
before people were being like like
people were on the path and then shaytan
came in and well I was great before yeah
before we Allah created the Hellfire
then a lot because even in Islamic who
believed there were people before us
some squares mentioned they were Jin
remember is the Andrew said to the uh to
Allah why are you going to create people
that are going to cause Mischief upon
the Earth the score is mentioned because
there were people doing that some
squirrels mentioned they were gin but
some squads mentioned could be different
creation Allah knows best you know so
Allah create the Hellfire and create
Paradise at the same time I don't know
which one's first I don't know if
someone knows can teach me ah
it's not made clear it's us yeah that's
what I know so when you create Paradise
he said to the angel Gabriel go look at
it he went he said oh Allah every person
you're going to create is going to come
here
every Paradise first you know if I do
remember then the time goes to the
Hellfire
then he wants the Hellfire he said No
One's Gonna come inside then Allah
surrounded Paradise with that which we
dislike but in a reality it's good for
us and he said go and look at it now he
went and he said I don't think no one's
gonna come inside so Paradise he said go
look at the Hell Fire Allah surrounded
with that we should attempt us angel
gabri will say everyone's gonna come
inside then Allah said as for Paradise
is a place of my Mercy as for the
Hellfire is a place of my anger you know
many people say why there is evil here
why Allah is the most wise the more just
Allah create place of pure good some
people don't they won't Paradise on this
life no that and guess Allah's wisdom
Allah create Paradise which is pure good
Allah the Hell Fire which is pure evil
then Allah create this life even good
and create us so it's upon us if we
really want good to choose the way to
leave it to good but if you want evil
choose the way to lead you to evil Allah
we guide him we show them the two paths
the evil path and the the good path
but it's up to him you know so Allah is
the most wise so God says
Allah has given us our own conscience to
make that decision whereas Creations
like the Angels they were only created
to worship Allah that's all they know so
when Allah created
us why did you make this creation when
like he said the Creations before
creating a Mischief upon the Earth
Allah says you know I know of which you
do not know and he presented amongst the
Angels items or objects again it's not
clear and he said to the angels name
these things Daniel said oh but we don't
know
you only told us of what we know already
and we seek more from what you tell us
can you name these things all of them
and he goes see you I know of what you
do not know and that's when the angel
frustrated not out of worship to Allah
but of respect from Allah all the Angels
is out of worship Allah but out of
respect yes so it's out of worship from
uh so it was right they do it yeah so
that's why we are the best operations to
we have our own conscience to make our
decisions of good and right at the end
of the day and we have to remember this
life is only I don't know about the best
of creation because because you know
there's someone say the Andrews but
family said that we are because of the
prophets and Messengers
said there's no point saying we are the
best or the best can I ask you a
question a serious question
what is stopping you I mean I don't mind
asking me questions yeah but what is
except Islam
what is the barrier that you think
that if that is a good it's a valid
reason for me to accept Islam now
because I want to accept now Islam
because I will get Good Deed by the way
you're not going to give me no money but
I'll get a good day but it's good for
you as well you understand and it's the
best thing like I said to your mouth is
a revert you understand
what is a valid reason that you think if
I do die today my love forbid like I
said you don't know I'm gonna die don't
let the Satan stop you and I Prophet
Muhammad taught us when a person wants
to become a Muslim
Satan will come to them they will put
many barriers your family you know
already you know uh or it's not the best
time and all of that yeah and all of
this reason is a valid reason before our
creator our Lord remember when I said if
I do save your life
if you are in the house and there's a
fire you would not say to me give me a
time before I thank you you will thank
me straight away you know straight away
you say thank you likewise you know no
you know the truth I mean you should
accept it straight away and step by step
start learning understand I think it's
because like many religions like God is
the center of the religion like in
Christianity in like in Islam every day
then like I find it hard to know whether
Islam is the correct one because I
believe the thing that stops me being a
Christian was the Bible because I found
it hard to believe a lot of what was in
the Bible so then I rejected it and then
I still believed in God in my heart but
I didn't have like a religion to kind of
follow like to lead me but like I'm the
one finding out about Islam I like it
but then I haven't even looked at like
um
so what if I'm just being naive and
following okay well I would say too
that's a good question there's over I
don't know how many religions out there
yeah
Allah you don't have to learn about
every religion okay why I'm saying that
when you look at Islam because Allah is
the most wise you know Allah knows that
our life will not enable us to study
every religion or philosophy yes that's
what Allah send out Islam and so on he
gave us so clear proofs to come to
conclusion with certainty Islam is the
truth and there's no doubt if Islam is
the truth whatever oppose it must be the
falsehood for example if I say my
brother Jamal Jamal is in Speaker's
Corner right now recording me
you regardless how many people make
philosophical ideas or philosophical
arguments Jamal is in China swimming
under the water I'm not going to accept
it and I don't have to spend my time to
study their reasons understand that's
why I bring you back to my point my
point here is when Allah created you he
created us with something called
Universal tools
what is our Universal tools it's our
cervical natural explanation
sound reasoning and our senses these
tools when you come when you that's why
you gravitate towards Islam why you
gravitate not just you
foreign
[Music]
this is a huge war that has been waged
against Islam if it was raged against
any religion or philosophy that original
would would die there is no war against
Christianity and Christianity is dying
like what Judaism Judaism is a tribal
God okay it's a God that cares about the
Israelites the rest of the people you
just served Israelites yeah which
doesn't make sense in a human being okay
so now when you look at Islam even there
is a there's a huge war against Islam
the fastest growing religion on the face
of the Earth and especially in the
western world is Islam who's doing the
job we as a Muslims we have to speak the
truth we are weak in comparison with the
weapons and the media that our opponents
possess however Allah mentioned that in
the Quran system
1400 years
it's Allah who sent he's a prophet with
Islam in order for Islam to Prevail all
other religions even if a disbelievers
dislike it
so how especially women they found that
in America in Britain America and
Germany and France majority of rivers
are women and of course they say women
oppress Islam oppressed women so I'm
saying that me myself and I observe that
with my own eyes
and I look back to the Quran it's a
prophecy that's unbelievable look at the
look at the world against Islam and
Islam is spreading people's accepted
Islam you know even now like I said
influences online famous people inclined
towards Islam because sister the war
that is happening now and guess Human
Nature
foreign
that's why they were fighting against
Islam because they have noticed the only
religion that is standing firm and it's
not backing down and it's fighting back
it's Islam against the evil ones
that's what increased my faith Islam is
the truth that's one of them but I will
give you something which give you
certainty
pay attention to this yeah and so forth
taking your time by the way thank you
very much for giving me your time so
Islam came to preserve five things yeah
Islam came to preserve five things Islam
came to preserve religion
what does that mean it means in Islam
we're not allowed to pray to any thing
beside Allah even we're not allowed to
pray to Prophet Muhammad
we're not allowed to be atheists
agnostic politics none of that and I
will tell you the reason the outcome of
not believing in the True Religion so
Islam we have to preserve Islam secondly
Islam so the outcome of preserving Islam
and worshiping the true God you start
preserving your intellects that's when
Islam anything that harms the intellect
is forbidden drugs alcohol is forbidden
actually you know we love coffee you
know you can't tell me about coffee
please
yes you will have coffee in Algeria I
think if you if you start Algerian man a
coffee comes out no blood let's give too
much coffee
they are strong my mother remember
strong coffee black strong you know
sugar no sugar it's like you know
the whole area
so
Islam's intellect is forbidden thirdly
Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why gambling and interest is
forbidden fourthly Islam came to
preserve
no that's a Islam came to preserve
lineage and the families that's why
fornication adultery is forbidden lastly
Islam came to preserve life that's why
anything harms our body our life is
forbidden killing innocent people is
forbidden committing Swiss sorry
committing suicide is forbidden so look
at when you worship the true God the
outcome of that you have a good Society
this very healthy things for our society
the opposite of that which majority of
our societies allow it those allow it
glamorize it and propagate it alcohol
destroy us individually collectively
gambling likewise interest make the rich
future poor poorer is a slavery likewise
for nikesh adultery destroy families
likewise and these evil things goes back
to what so no Worship in the true God
but yet there is some people are
benefiting from these vices from alcohol
gambling interest you know this
prostitution and so on
times are those who are in power and
when I say those who are in power is not
necessarily I mean I'm speaking about
the politicians no those are behind you
know those in power charging big
companies bankers and so on they are
making money from it
so they look at Islam as a threat for
their business even though they know
Islam is coming with the legislation
that is good for us individually and
collectively but because they are evil
they don't care about humans they care
about money so what they're gonna do
because they have lots of money they're
going to utilize the media to make us
look bad to make Islam look bad even
though I've just broken it down that
Islam is good for us individually and
collectively so the question you ask
yourself
how man how this man Prophet Muhammad
who existed 1400 years ago
who couldn't read and write he came in
the middle of death from the middle of
this Mecca at that time there was no
civilization around him you know
he came with the perfect way of life on
the other hand we have these politicians
socialists scientists studied in the
best universities around the world yet
they cannot resolve the problems we are
facing because Prophet Muhammad his
religion that he came with with his five
Universal Necessities that come to
preserve came from the almighty Creator
who wants good for you and for me and
for everyone you know when Allah just
laid something there's no evil desires
involved there's no bias involved but
when humans let's just State something
there's evil desires I'll give you
example of that I can go to shop next to
a shop of license I can sell drugs yeah
the police will come arrest me
yeah they want to arrest the shopkeeper
even though what I'm selling equals the
same weather shopkeeper in the off
license is selling alcohol because the
same harm that I'm selling the the drugs
cause likewise majority of crimes has
been carried out because of alcohol so
why I'm gonna get arrested and the
shopkeeper who's causing the same harm
there's no getting arrested because from
alcohol they're making a lot of money
there's high taxes you see that's why
when you have when you do not follow God
you contradict yourself that's why
Islamic Sharia you know and let me
clarify something when we say Sharia I'm
not talking about this Muslim ignorance
ones who say we come in here take over
the country and force everyone to do
this so that that's not Islamic teaching
by the way that is a lie which the media
propagates Islamic Sharia
you don't say is
a Divine Law
of your parents
take care of your neighbors worshiping
Allah the most the the the the the most
important one worship you create
according to his teaching likewise take
care of the environment likewise have
punishment for the evil ones for the
criminals that's why every out of
experienced sister those who have
problems with the capital punishment
that Islam came with sometimes they are
ignorant about Islam or they themselves
are criminals for example if someone
murders someone here you know when you
put him in prison
I mean I mentioned a long time may I
forgive me I won't president's country
this prison here is already in I'm not a
glamorizer don't go prison okay but
literally it's holiday in
you I remember when I was in streets I
used to eat once a day
you know dead three times a day
you have television if you are good they
give you PlayStation 2 at that time then
you have association association you
play football then you go gym
it's a nice life you don't have to pay
tax I don't have to pay bills especially
the bills to hide now right
you don't have to pay rent you know none
of that so so
is coming to protect us do you think
there's any country with this what's the
country you think is the most like
living to the trivia law the most Saudi
I believe Saudi doing it they have
mistakes no doubts but you know they're
not perfect but Saudi is the most con
that the country that Implement Sharia
it's just interest insurance
for me
it's good for everyone but why people
hate it
like I said ignorance or themselves are
criminals who wants to do crimes and go
get free for example it I've noticed
when people have problems
they argue and they defend the criminals
more than the victim Africa bro what
about the victim man the woman being
raped and you're focusing about the guy
doesn't make any sense to me that's my
point my point is when Allah just say
something there's no bias and I'll tell
you what is difference between
with the natural remedy
or because natural remedy what it does
it treats you from the roots
you know when you go to someone
naturalist he will tell you look let me
see what you're eating what is your diet
and so on when you go to GP he give you
a paracetamol what is the painkiller do
pain killer doesn't not deal with the
roots with the problem from The Roots
yeah what it does just maintain your or
manage your symptoms or covers it up but
the Islamic Sharia deals with the roots
problems that's why we have something
called
even leads to evil it's evil
so if I know by me bringing the singers
here's country and paying the money to
gamorize uh killing and being a gangster
and disrespecting woman and so on I said
wait wait this is going to create a
generation who started suspecting their
sisters and a woman so I'm gonna stop
that no I give the money and glamorize
them then I said yeah you you make your
own choice no I carry other people
because sometimes people cannot make up
especially when they're in drugs and so
on understand so my point to bring you
back when you look to Islamic Sharia
said he gives us sword proof why Islam
is the truth and when it is the truth
whatever God against his falsehood
Christianity doesn't make any sense God
became a man that God died for your sins
but God's created with the sin the Bible
the Old Testament
God said that the Israelite to kill
children because something happened 500
years ago that is Haram in Islam Allah
said
likewise
no it's Samuel Soul yes Samuel likewise
God regrets even the prophets who are
our best example the role model to
follow they are worse than Starling you
know Stalin
Stalin Mo whose name uh Hitler and so on
so the point here is that when you look
to him
is a perfect way of life and he looks
Hinduism they don't even believe in God
it's a philosophy you know but Islamic
is good for you for you intellectually
spiritually physically socially which is
everything is connected
I want to create Islam is not just for
you sister for me to be inside the most
no it's not for the government to
implement it you know to implement Islam
and the outcome of implementing Islam
looks at the crime rates in Saudi and
the Muslim countries and compare it to
the Western World which we call
civilized country I don't know I want to
understand what does it mean civilized
is to have a clean Road that's something
good but if you have a clean Road and a
man sleeping sleeping with the with
animals just crazy stuff happening you
know there's no civilization that's why
his name came to take people from True
Darkness into the True Light and from
True backwardness into true civilization
and there's many prophecies I can give
you now to show you what is them is the
truth and why Mohammed the messenger of
Allah is a true message of Allah I can
give you two incidents to show you
Muhammad is not Allah
okay one of them a man came to Prophet
Muhammad
this man was married to a woman that she
doesn't like him anymore
and he wants to stay with her he loves
her I mean love that everyone save her
so he's the full behind the streets she
doesn't want him anymore Prophet
Muhammad went to her and he told her why
don't you go back to him and remember
she believes he's a prophet Allah and
she must obey him
that's the foundation yeah then she said
your own message of Allah are you
telling me as a message of Allah or you
just try to mediate he said no if he was
a liar imagine I'm a liar come to your
prophet and he's my friend yes and he's
married to you to another sister then
what I'm going to say is my friend I'm
going to be on his side so I'm gonna lie
to you so listen God told me you need to
go back to him but why he said to I said
no God never told me I'm just trying to
help but if you want to go back go back
if not it's up to you that's not
characteristics of a liar
no way another incident during his
lifetime he had a son called Ibrahim
his son died
Ibrahim died
same day when there was Eclipse you will
meet those Eclipse here his companions
were not familiar with the clips so they
tried to connect the dots his son passed
away there is Eclipse so they said the
reason there's Eclipse because Prophet
Muhammad passed away if he was a liar
remember the liar would try to utilize
any opportunity to back up his claim
what he said he said no he has nothing
to do with no one's life no one's deaf
when you see it is a sign from Allah go
pray what he did he connect them to
Allah and there's many incidents when
you see this man is a truthful person
bear in mind his own people used to call
him Assad the trustworthy the truthful
person so when you look at Prophet
Muhammad's biography look at his
legislation
how we lived like the example I gave
incidents you know
even the Quran in the Quran Allah said
yes
creation because we have to take over
Allah but Allah if you want if if Allah
wants to show us the importance of his
creation he will take out by it he said
o Muhammad you're not crazy person
and you are upon a great conduct
when a once Prophet Muhammad he was
walking and then grabbed him from behind
and pulled him
his companions got angry even because of
the mark with the pulling he sent to him
he said may Allah have mercy upon my
brother Moses Musa the prophet Moses he
said he was harmed more and he was
patient and Prophet Muhammad gave him
what the man said give me some money
gave him a sheep the man went back to
his people he said I came from someone
does not fear poverty
it is a team you crazy man out there you
you know even when you look at
what they call it uh the story of I was
gonna mention the story of uh uh Abu
Bakr said his best companion his best
companion brought his father to Prophet
Muhammad prophet Muhammad said why do
this you should call me we'll go to him
he is older than us you know even
Prophet Muhammad when he was in Medina a
Jewish man had the problem with a Muslim
so a Muslim they want to provide
Muhammad to judge between them Prophet
Muhammad judge in favor of the Jewish
man
with him that's why even the Jewish
people at that time they never used to
go back to their rabbis because their
rabbis used to take bribes they said no
let's go back to Muhammad even they
don't believe it's a prophet and I'll go
back to him he will judge us accordingly
with Justice you know so there's many
many proofs I can give you when you look
to any religion it is no way from God so
you don't have to because you cannot
spend all your lives on your own
religious it's too much but this
sufficient for someone who with a sound
reasoning and I believe you are one of
them sound natural inclination inclined
towards Islam what do you figure has
said so far does it mixes yeah I get
that I just before it's like a week ago
I spoke to my friend who was a Muslim so
I just want to put here I have many
fixed holding he was a Muslim and then
he left the religion and I told him
maybe I'm a little bit interested in
Islam and I told him like some of my
questions and then his
views were like he was saying when
Muhammad got the messages from God he
like how can you say that he didn't
change and manipulate them before we put
them in to told them to people and made
it into the Quran like how did how do
you know he didn't change his opinion
like put his opinion into this into what
came from Allah
firstly we have to establish that this
man is a trust really truthful yeah
honest okay secondly we I'll just give
you an example of Muhammad was not
manipulated one I've done the story
where I could have said to the woman he
could have told her Allah told me did he
say that he you say that you're with me
so we can see many incidents where
Muhammad if he was a liar he would have
say something with his own opinion for
example the Quran is a proof that is not
from Prophet Muhammad because there's
verse in the Quran Prophet Muhammad for
making some mistakes
hang on uh
I hope I'm translating
but Allah correcting him
why is going to make himself look he's
making mistakes
do you understand that's why his wife
she said there's many verses to prove
that Muhammad was honest man one of the
verses Allah said yes
from that which you have from your lord
and one of them there's a verse which
our mother Aisha his wife be pleased
with her she said this verse is so clear
Prophet Muhammad did not manipulate
which verse Prophet Muhammad there was a
woman there was he had a son called
Usama
sorry okay in Arabic foreign
came to remove this yeah take care of
the orphans treat them nice but they're
not your son they have their own parents
and by the way to mentioned another
story
when his parents came to look for him
when they found that he's in Mecca
he said
what I saw from this man I will never
exchange him with no one they said
how dare you this is where are you we
Palace your family he said no no no I'm
not going to leave this man his
truthfulness trustworthy so again it's
another story so this man is a truthful
person how man is going to choose
someone and he was not forcing him or
something who's taking care of him
anyway when he was married to uh
was married to Josh they had problems
Prophet Muhammad told him they're going
to get divorced and you're gonna marry
but at that time from the other pagans
teaching which has nothing to do from
God that you're not allowed to get
married to the ex-wife of your adopted
son
to deal with it Allah revealed the verse
that Prophet Muhammad is hesitating to
mention it
wait wait he's if I'm a liar consider us
understand there's no one worst in Lion
then someone claiming to be a prophet of
God you know
regards how much you like if you claim
to the prophet of God you are the worst
liar because you are saying what you do
this because God told me how do you know
that because I know you believe that
when Jesus comes back to Earth that's
the day is that from the size of our
yeah yeah so what if somebody comes out
to you on his eye
that's a good point but we have criteria
in the Quran in the Sunnah the criteria
is Jesus will come from Syria will be
descending he will see descending for
the Angels holding him also he has a
curly hair okay and his hair is like
just have ablution okay and there's many
uh what they call it many signs before
that so we're
don't get it wrong you know there's
people claim to be Jesus before yeah
yeah I remember Allah exposed them
and one of them it was in the time of
the islamia he claimed to be Jesus
so they took him to the leader the
leader said I'm going to kill you he
said no no joke I'm Not Jesus
he's changed you know so Jesus when he
come there's before Maddie comes so
there's many signs you know even some
people close to Maddie huh
no matter before no no
yeah yeah that's what I said all right
let's just imagine before yeah so so
what are we saying so there is
going to mention establish Allah is the
most wise you know
the most ones will never leave us with
confusion yes Allah will allow some
people to as a test to see who's going
to stand from or not but eventually will
expose them
at the time Prophet Muhammad there were
other people came to the prophet of God
but Allah expose them and humiliate them
except Prophet Muhammad did you know
there is a verse in the Quran Allah this
verse was revealed Prophet Muhammad was
in a battlefield yeah and his companions
used to guard him outside his tent the
verse was revealed that Allah will
protect you of Muhammad
he came out he told his companies leave
me imagine the time of battle his
enemies they waited for any opportunity
to kill him and he said leave me and
Allah reveal the verse in the Quran is
not going to die and you will not be
killed until you convey the message when
this verse was revealed and Allah will
protect you when this verse was revealed
Prophet Muhammad was not behind hiding
in the Fortress
because I can hide in my house for 25
years and I said look Allah told me and
I have many enemies outside by the way
and Allah told me I'm not going to be
killed mom I did but imagine still Allah
told me I'm not going to be killed and
guess who I am I'm in a battle fighting
with the food and I'll tell you I'm
gonna convey my message and historically
from a Muslim sources and non-muslim
sources that what has occurred with the
prophet Muhammad before he died Islam
was completed he looked as companions
leading the prayer this is not a
statement of someone is a normal man
in the stand because when the people
light we Prophet God they always say
something vague or they hide and so on
but what prophet Muhammad said and and
the prophecy that came with and so on is
so perfect so if Prophet Muhammad wants
to manipulate there's many situations
when we see that he was good for him but
what he did he said something would go
and guess him as a human being from a
human angle for example I'm a liar I'm
because I correcting myself because if I
do correct myself remember these people
believe in prophet of God they're gonna
say God is lying man
in the Quran
um
if you make up anything about about
Allah Allah will take you civilian
destroy you meaning straight away
as for him dying after by praising
whatever this is not the first the verse
means straight away by the fact that
Prophet Muhammad said Islam who spread
far is far west historically Islam
spread all the way to China and all the
way to and they will say spend even now
America and so on again you know that's
why as a Muslim we don't believe Islam
is the truth because our dream in my
house I was sleeping as a sister I
believe Islam is the truth
because I dream of prophet Muhammad came
to me or one day I was in prison and you
know I saw Jesus
this person experience okay but Islam is
based upon the universe approves which
you and I and all of us here we can
analyze and come to conclusion that must
be the truth anyone with a sound
reasoning included so what this person
said the biography of prophet Muhammad
and the Quran Refuge him
manipulating or adding no no you can see
clearly even there is a verse Allah says
yes
what happened a man came to Prophet
Muhammad he was a blind man
His companion Prophet Muhammad was busy
preaching to the Arab pagans to the help
to the leaders so he came to him and he
wants to ask him Prophet Muhammad was
like wait wait you know because he's
following wait let me I'm busy with them
Allah send the verses correct him and
Prophet Muhammad said you should not do
that those guys that are going to listen
to you they are stubborn focus on those
who are seeking the truth
if he's alive why why he's gonna mention
this verse he's gonna hide it or we're
gonna change it he didn't so that's why
one of our Scholars there's two of them
even has my diary may Allah have mercy
upon him and even
him he said anyone study the biography
and the history of prophet Muhammad with
sincerity they will come to conclusion
this man must be the prophet of the most
high
and then
okay
we're gonna compromise yeah all right go
on
the thing about the 92 virgin girl that
don't like it
no we have not nice to mobile T-Mobile
there's no version T-Mobile
72 version by the way there's no had it
it's not it's not true 72 version of the
matter someone dies and you get 72
version yeah yeah there's no holidays
about that that's not yes no and firstly
that's yeah I noticed you heard it from
uh what's his name you heard it from uh
idios
sister everyone said many things
remember the criteria even in the Quran
Allah mentioned majority of people like
to follow the desires so majority is not
a criteria so that's come from
no no I'm not saying there is a weak
narration or an authentic narration
about it yes so and remember
even
a line in the Quran was for the woman in
Paradise
what the eyes never seen and the heart
never heard a fortkoff and is never had
off the scores Islam mentioned how come
in the Quran Allah never mentioned in
details what the woman is going to have
in Paradise he said because a woman
naturally from a nature to be shy you
understand so it's to go in line with
that nature I'll never miss indeed as a
reward for the woman rather the woman in
Paradise will be more beautiful than the
woman the Muslim woman it will be more
beautiful than the woman of Paradise in
the stand and the reward They will
receive better than them you understand
so alhamdulillah so this stuff people
just say similar to Virgin uh it's a 72
to mobiles man it's just a it's a
nonsense but you know if Allah wants to
give what would say to look sister if
Allah is the most just
like I said to you you and I and all of
us here we have small knowledge correct
small wisdom
and we cannot encompasses everything our
knowledge correct so is it logical for
us to try to judge or dictate the one
dictate to the one who has a perfect
knowledge perfect wisdom what to do it's
not rational
because
um my ncf is limited to how I'm gonna
judge how I'm going to utilize my limits
intellect to judge the one who has
absolute wisdom absolute knowledge
doesn't make any sense so when Allah the
crude something sister there's not any
doubt it's good for us but Allah is not
going to wait for you to ask you if you
like it or not you understand that's why
Allah mentioned the Quran Allah said if
the truth if the truth follow people's
desires the heavens and the Earth will
be corrupted the scholars of Islam
mentioned meaning that we lack quick
things
even though it's a bad for us but we
don't know it but Allah knows that
sometimes you dislike some element in
the Quran
perhaps you hate something English is
good for you and Allah
perhaps you love something which is
better which is bad for you and Allah
finished the verse with
Allah knows and you do not know
so no doubt there's some legislation
that some of us may be going to struggle
to understand it but there is a Basics
to understand everything that the
Creator is all knowing always when you
say something it's not gonna ask me like
for example someone came to me he said
you know I said worship Allah he says
but before God created me he never asked
me to create me
look it's a nonsensical argument I said
wait so you want God to ask you before
create you but in order to ask you he
has to create you
this summer stream you know but if he
created you and you know he's your God
lose his excite you cannot submit to him
you don't ask him God it should do you
should do that
many people don't understand who is
Allah and this question comes from the
atheist who originally from Christian
background difficult is a man or
something no Allah is the almighty
al-jabbar the compeller man the most
beneficence the most strongest
the one who overpower everything
and you know when you understand Allah
is an attribute and you compare yourself
to the creation of Allah will humble you
and you say oh Allah forgive me for my
shortcomings that's what Islam teaches
humbleness When you pray him and you
finish the prayer where we say I stuck
through Allah
what does it mean a seek Allah
forgiveness a seek Allah forgiveness
meaning regardless how much you wash
Allah I wash Allah or anyone else
is right over us because just the eyes
the blessings of the eyes just the
blessings that we have you are a worship
how many years been sleeping ask if you
calculate our life majority of times or
sleeping studying doing something to do
with the words of Allah
that's why we answered into Paradise
with the mercy of Allah Prophet Muhammad
they said to all messenger of Allah even
you you enter Paradise with the mercy of
Allah it's even me
because we feel like it understand so
yes yes
everything so Allah create everything
Allah knows everything Allah has written
everything in the preserved tablets
if we are gonna be following him or not
from before yeah
why wouldn't he want to like rewrite it
and make it so that we follow him
tablet I mean you know what is in a
preset tablet you don't know it's
written for you
that's it so now you choose because
Allah knows okay and Allah has a perfect
knowledge okay that Allah knowing
something doesn't know necessarily or
does not negate uh
us going to party but we don't know
so Allah knows but we don't know so
Allah tells us okay so you have to
choose so now you cannot be at home like
Allah knows how much money you're gonna
make yes are you going to be at home say
oh Allah because you know how much money
you're going to make I'm gonna make so
I'm gonna be sitting down you don't want
to say that you're gonna go out take the
means likewise when you come to guidance
like what you're doing sister what
you're doing is good you taking the
steps into guidance that's what Allah
mentioned the Quran
seek my guidance I will guide you but
Allah is not in need of your worship
that's why we are in need of worshiping
Allah know the other way around you
understand because we are in need to
live this life which is full of evil to
survive in this life is by worshiping
Allah and following Allah's teaching
you know so now imagine you're traveling
to Birmingham there's one way to
Birmingham One Way lead to Cardiff
Cardiff is evil there's a lot of people
killing each other in Birmingham is
peaceful you're gonna say oh Allah you
know you're gonna no you're gonna choose
the path where it is more safety and
more peaceful you understand and
whatever you're going to choose Allah
knows it subhanallah so it's upon you to
take step now
yeah you want to become with them yeah
not nice yeah no problem no problem
first
I mean good no doubt but I would say to
you that are you like I said to you are
you guaranteed to leave tomorrow
okay what what is okay no problem but
what is do you have anything that is
stopping you or you just want you on
time or something I think I want to know
really about the subject like I I'm like
I'm on the edge right now I hardly know
anything like I want to I think you know
more some Muslims man to be honest it's
true
you're always then like even me as a
Muslim sorry sorry I'm a Muslim I'm
still learning you know I'm still
learning you know but I don't want to
put pressure on you if you want to learn
more I mean the reason I ask a question
ask that question if you have any
questions you can ask I don't mind
you have any questions
do you think you know like if you see if
you see like someone's murdered somebody
so there's a killer and you look at the
reason why he's killed that person and
you look at he was born everyone is born
as a clean slate do you believe that
everyone is born
yeah yeah yeah but yeah we don't believe
I can wear a Christian if you're born as
a sinner we don't believe that yeah
for example
say you maybe had abusive parents maybe
then was like rejected from society and
then up to the point where he kills the
guy you've done the same would you make
the same decision as him if you had done
had the same experience do you think or
do you think it sounded free choice what
is the question I get if so if you live
the same life as a murderer
he killed an innocent person okay you
live the same life as him okay from zero
to the time yeah would you make the what
do you think
you would make the same decision to kill
do you think it's because you were born
as a clean slate you are all of your
experiences because of your experiences
do you think that then you would also
make the same decision killing him or
you think because you have your own free
will you wouldn't do that and you would
that's right first let us break it down
for you okay there's a factors in Islam
because you know like I said Islam is
upon Justice yes there are certain
things that Islam take into
consideration about the person okay so
if a person was raised up in society
when he was
abused that's you know harmed and
psychology that affect him mentally did
affect him then Allah is the most just
you know but if the person because I
mean I came from Algeria I saw people
getting killed full of me I I I I lived
in a time when there was Civil War in
Algeria I was 13 selling in the market
like today I remember it was first day
evening my cousin was next to me there
was a guy it was a police officer
two people came parked the car came out
show him in the head when I was 12 all
right I started carrying a knife when I
was nine ninth count nine back home you
know what kind of knives and so on yeah
but I I never fought in my life that is
okay because they started within us
natural inclination that teach us within
you tell you what you're doing is evil
you know so Allah is a more just if the
person become psychologically well
the pen is being lift up from three
types of people one of them someone who
is insane you know but if the person is
not really it's not affecting
emotionally that doesn't allow him to go
kick innocent people but if that
happened then there's a narration
Prophet Muhammad as I was a man before
us he killed 99 men
he killed 99 men and you know the story
if you know what it's too much I need to
stop he wanted to worshiper
and this Hadith or this story there's
many benefits we can learn that when you
want to seek ask question you don't go
to a worshiper it has to be a scholar as
well someone of knowledge the worshiper
said there is no
no way there's no hope for you man you
get 99 man bro there's no hope he killed
him 100 then he regretted he went to a
scholar he said there is nothing between
you and repent to Allah
you know he said however don't stay in
this Society this site is evil go to the
other Village on his way there he died
then they measured he was more close to
the society or the environment or the
town of righteousness and I forgive him
Allah is the most merciful you know when
people ask about this person that person
remember that's his creation and Allah
is the most merciful but also
Allah is just too understand so that's
why imagine I've been forced to kill
someone you know if someone
Force I don't know about four sin
because you can but imagine someone uh
hold my hand they hold me falsely I'm
not even fighting me hold my hand and
then start stabbing someone they hold me
by the hand that the knife was in my
hand but I've been fools I couldn't you
know how long will hold you accountable
for it Allah will not hold you
comfortable I cannot imagine you know
the people that they walk sleeping you
know and they do something while they're
sleeping the past believed from them
because why they're not there so Allah
is the most just you know hola sometimes
we think about people Allah that's what
Allah will declare for the truth when
it's clear you know like I'm not even
for example if I drink alcohol but I
didn't know it was Haram in Islam Allah
anything that harms the body yeah that
is forbidden okay for example me yeah
for example Once We Were Young back home
yeah we had a boat of water like two
litters me and my friend water is harder
to drink water correct but me and my
friend says let us drinking Non-Stop
I've been drinking after I was going to
die I didn't finish it but you should
have run with the whole water yeah now
that is how I was doing
even though the water
that's why is
the principles that's why sister you
know when we say Islam is valid for
every place and every uh time because
Islam is based upon General Universal
principles which school has the right
rulings from it Prophet Muhammad said do
not harm yourself and do not harm others
this applied to marriage this apply in
transaction is applied in anything that
you do in your life there are no time
yourself and do not have others
understand so there's many principles
coffee like I said we love coffee but if
it's a harmful for you don't drink it
you know like sugar likewise eating
sugar too much if it's harmful don't
drink it too much of anything yeah you
know
it's how you run it now but it's very
important yeah but then then you also
just think yeah that's why the prophet I
saw some said hello
the extremists they will be destroyed
extreme in what not just in religion
even in a religion system even in
religion in worshiping but to go extreme
is forbidden be balanced
I mean he has not just a it was like a
way like when he's selling food and so
on not even the adult Allah created this
life based upon Justice and the most
and the greatest Justice is to worship
your creator that's why there's three
types of Oppression there's a three
types of Oppression yes the first one
oppression against your creator
because why is oppression oppression
when you put something in the wrong
place or you give something to someone
does not deserve so you worship someone
other than a true creator you are
committed Injustice the second
oppression when you oppress the people
the first oppression when you oppress
yourself
see and Islam oppression is forbidden
even non-muslims we're not allowed to
oppress the non-muslims prophet Muhammad
told us that Allah will accept the
prayer the supplication of the one who
has been oppressed even if he's a
non-muslim that's why we have Prophet
Muhammad told us fear the prayer and the
supplication of the oppressed one
guys why is um I don't know if the
Muslim world is reacting to this a lot
but you know what's happening in
Afghanistan like I feel like everyone's
very silent about how Islam is being
implemented there and how women aren't
allowed to go to school and like I don't
really hear much about anyone reacting
to it at all like from there but people
are like representing Islam in that way
I know they're not the true
representation of Islam like they've
gone on a very extreme
yes
system is corrupted yeah however
many things be said about them have to
verify
because if with the non-muslims I have
to be just and I should not just listen
to the media what about our Muslim
brothers because they are still my
Muslim Brothers but I don't agree with
the stuff they do okay so how about them
preventing a woman coming to
the schools islamically a woman allowed
to seek knowledge Prophet Muhammad told
us seeking knowledge is compulsory
obligatory upon every Muslim male and
female okay however I don't know what is
the situation exactly I cannot just take
it from the Western media the Western
media are the same media who told us
that Saddam had a nuclear weapon and
destroyed Iraq and Afghanistan so I
don't believe everything they say but
people are speaking about on media
however sister why no one is speaking
about our Muslim sisters in France not
allowed to study in schools and college
universities because they cover
themselves why no one speaking about it
neighbor
Afghanistan is far away from us if you
have a food and you want to give it who
is the one who deserves it your next
door neighbor first don't go to you from
Bush you go to Brixton oh you're from
London you go to to Scotland you
understand so not if you have problem
with preventing women from seeking
knowledge why the British government and
American government and European
government are not speaking against the
French government for not allowing a
woman to go to what is the problem with
covering yourself I don't understand
yeah
I don't understand once I was on the
train
you know I was coming from the gym and
there was a Muslim sister and this guy
is having problem with her he didn't
know I was a Muslim I said I said let me
ask you a question yeah just let me just
break it down for you to show you what
you're doing just foolishness
what is your problem she's just covering
herself why are you angry
yeah
you know it was nice yeah I said let me
repeat it you seeking bread she's
sitting over here she's covered up you
why are you angry
I think everybody likes it yeah the
choice of Free Will for women and to
like cover themselves she is free will
it covered I understand no he's angry
because he cannot see her body
he wants to see our body he wants to see
what is in there he's getting irritated
that's a reality you understand
I mean you came excuses yeah but the guy
was a big guy man and the sisters
walk around life with you know knowing
in what direction they want to go yeah
yeah I mean it's again they could be um
intimidated by the certainty that a
religious person like that female had
like yeah some people are a bit more
lost in terms of when you see someone
that's very thorough following their
religion in a very okay to be honest
coherent way it is something that can
irritate something so sorry if she was a
Muslim and covered up you have no
problem yeah if she's a Muslim no no no
no no no no I'm just saying if she was a
Muslim and she didn't cover herself she
would have no problem I'm telling you
the problem is he's been brainwashed by
the media or that's how I can take a
break I'd have been brainwashed by the
media or he thinks she's going to do
something okay because the media tells
him oh he's just angry at me like I was
surprised I mean as look when I say a
Jewish woman on the train you know I
mean let's look this is Jewish person
they kill the Palestinian Muslims in
Palestine she's gonna kill me oh no no
she's a woman she's influen her religion
she's respectful if someone's gonna harm
him I'm gonna defend her even if it's a
Jewish man I'm gonna do that that's what
Islam teach me I'm not gonna
say I'm not gonna I'm not gonna too many
microphones man like an operation man
yeah I'm not gonna the problem is
they've been brainwashed you know and
you know after you clocked on you know
he's like yeah it's true I don't
understand I was just sitting down you
why are you having problem with so
so sister you know
just tell you something to conclude with
that the problem is that people claiming
that they don't have free will in France
the woman that
family
lucky like what what I've seen in the UK
is for Christians I feel like there's
not really many real questions anymore
like the people that say the question
and for Islam there is
I've met a few Muslims that I think
cartoon Muslims but still I think there
is like even I go to UNI or Queen Mary
and they
like there's a lot of Muslims there that
they they call themselves Muslims but
then I don't see the true Islam in it
which is puts me off as well because I'm
like our people are
following the religion but the way they
want it to be but yeah that's that's the
point system I was going to say to you
Islam teach us who should not connect or
blindfold anyone we only take our role
model as as we take our role model or we
follow
and Prophet Muhammad and his companions
as for other Muslims at the end of the
day they are human beings okay like you
know like Christians you know so the the
they're still muslim okay but doesn't
mean they have to be perfect you know
but no doubt what you saying the Muslim
out there should take advice and try to
implement Islam the way the Islam was
implemented when Islam was implemented
correctly Nations countries became
Muslim just by because of the people
Behavior you understand like I mentioned
this story many times when my wife
became a Muslim I mean I met her way
after when I got married to her her
mother was not happy with me she didn't
like me she was very angry with me you
know so I once I said to my wife let's
go visit your mom we want to visit our
mom you know she's an atheist I mean
she's confused one day Christian when
the atheist I don't know where she's not
a guide anyway so we want to see her you
know the fact that was the first time I
would see her when she saw me how I
treated my wife and how I treated her by
buying her gift no she likes me man
she's driving me crazy oh I want to come
you see so they say actions louder than
speak alone in words yeah so you know
but at the end of the day when you look
even me I'm not perfect I have my own
struggle that's why sorry that's why
sister we really look at someone who
will say you know I'm not gonna expect
this person to be perfect
but if you expect me to be perfect then
I'm Gonna Let You Down and anyone else
you know even your sister only gonna
become Muslim in Allah
you know no one is perfect all of us we
have our own struggles our own mistakes
but Islam teach us that be honest if you
make mistakes I made mistake may Allah
forgive me you understand but no doubt
that should encourage us to do more good
details and we should behave correctly
especially as a Muslim you know we have
to Islam pay attention to good manners
but there's one thing good manners they
should have good manners
let me ask the Muslims there's two type
of good manners we finish all three well
there was the first one first time many
people focus on people as long as you be
good to your people to the people no no
the first to show our good manners with
our creator
creator has given you everything and
you're not doing nothing for him who is
our good manners second watch the people
you understand but many people miss the
first one and focus on being good to the
people yes be good to the be good to the
people Savage recommended Islam highly
recommend it you know so
do you have Instagram
I'll show you our Instagram
page you can contact me or not me
because I know my channel I don't have a
personal uh Instagram this is our one
okay yeah you can take a picture if you
want to not forget
and you can see our Channel there all
right take care of yourself have a nice
evening all right take care bye bye
thanks you're welcome
by the way the Bible is asking so
sometimes Brothers some of us come pray
pray if you tell me Allah have mercy
upon him there's a nice way that I can
share with people it will tell me I
mentioned even at best was teaching
message
started what ignoring the person until
Isha comes in
are you going to teach me
are you going to teach me the Sunnah I
saw Prophet Muhammad
combined between the Maghrib prayer and
Isha prayer when there was no rain or
severe wind
why to remove the hardship
upon Him commented on this narration in
the fatawah he said if a preacher would
die is saying something to someone and
he believes that he has to carry on
there's greater good you know he's
allowed to delay
understand
is between when he comes in all the way
to Asia time or something said when the
redness disappeared and there's still
Daylight by the way ma don't say you
know this I'll be that there they say
don't pray